I'm joined from Berlin by the chief
economist at berenberg bank hoggish
meeting and here in the studio by Tomas
Vela deck he's the senior international
economist at Barclays well Thomas let me
start with you the euro fell against
both the dollar and sterling today on
foreign exchanges or sensibly because of
mrs merkel's lackluster performance is
this necessarily bad news for the
eurozone well I guess it depends I guess
the key issue here is that if you look
at the possible Jamaica coalition people
are talking now about the AAP and the
CDU have sort of a logically similar
views of how to deal with the euro area
while the Green Party is quite an
opposing view and I think that perhaps
that was reflected in market pricing
today that is not clear to which extent
some of the solutions that have been
proposed like very present might fall
well that should be feasible now okay
well let me bring you in at this point
Germany has never had a so-called
Jamaica coalition between the CDU the
FDP and the Greens at national level
Jamaica of course because those are the
colors of the different parties black
yellow and green look how easy is it
going to be frankly Merkel to put such a
coalition together it is not going to be
easy this is a difficult combination
however having said that this is exactly
the kind of things that Merkel is very
good at she has a lot of experience of
bringing difficult people including some
difficult males together to get an
agreement and with her appearance even
with her experience she will very likely
get this Jamaica coalition together and
it will probably work for the full
four-year term well let me remind you
both what the brexit secretary David
Davis said last year he said we're too
valuable a market for Europe to shut off
within minutes of a vote for brexit the
CEOs of Mercedes BMW Volkswagen and Audi
will be knocking down Chancellor
Merkel's door demanding that there be no
barriers to German access to the British
market whoa what do you think of that
Thomas I mean it doesn't sound on the
face of it as so mrs. Merkel is going to
be jumping in on this well I think that
the government will pursue a policy of
continuity of the previous brexit
strategy and I think the challenges to
the European very broadly also if you
look at hungry
Poland perhaps the witch you know
there's some inter perhaps some people
would say anti-european sentiments there
recently well sort of lead Germany to
try and continue in unite Europe behind
one negotiation stance of it with
respect to the UK so therefore I think
it's unlikely that you'll see major
changes after this election oh good you
go along with that I mean is it fairly
unlikely that mrs. Merkel is going to
jump in and try and get involved to give
German car manufacturers a better chance
of a tariff free access to the UK market
this is a very interesting point this
issue namely that German industry would
like tariff free access to the UK is
discussed a lot in the UK it's rarely
ever discussed this side of the channel
this brexit issue from the continental
European perspective is a major
political challenge it is not an issue
where narrow economic interests will
play any significant role in shaping the
German and European negotiating position
the cutter the priority of the eu-27 is
to keep the eu-27 together to strengthen
the coherence of the eurozone and the
eu-27 access to the comparatively small
UK market if you see it from the big
European continent is not a key concern
anywhere over here so Holger the treasom
and David Davis and really wasting their
time by trying to appeal over the heads
of Michel Barnier to the the Heads of
Government of the eu-27 yes absolutely
the eu-27 are comparatively United on
that and trying to appear to individual
heads of government will only result in
a further waste of time because once
again this is an issue brexit where the
eu-27 whatever there are the
difficulties and differences are are
comparatively United they all want
Britain to pay there Li good use right
Thomas what about the eurozone and off
chances of reforms to the eurozone I
mean macro is making a big speech
tomorrow in this subject the assumption
was that Merkel would give him the sort
of backing to do so but if she's going
to be tired out and that cobbling
together a coalition
this doesn't really bode well for a
particular because the fpd doesn't
really support closer European
integration does it well I would say you
know one important thing to be said is
that all parties support European
integration just in different sort of
points of view and they have different
points of view and there's different
ways of European integration and the
timing of president macron speech
tomorrow is actually very important
because one could say initially the plan
was to actually get some of these ideas
into the next coalition agreement so
everyone is going to be watching very
closely what he's going to say tomorrow
but I think that the Jamaica
constellation would likely make much
more difficult to make significant
progress on things like the euro area
finance minister over the next four
years lost word to you in Berlin if mrs.
Merkel has to put together this
coalition she's going to have to offer
government positions to the greens and
the F DP what about Wolfgang schäuble of
the finance ministers position is he in
danger of having his job bartered away
to one of the other parties yes that is
indeed a significant probability as it's
now three parties award one senior drops
in government having said that for the
possibility is not so certain for the
possibility that Chauvelin moves on from
the Finance Ministry to some other job
then the Finance Ministry would probably
be taken over by the Liberals the FDP
and in their attitudes towards European
integration they are very very similar
to shortly in other words not much would
change in the actual German policy
approach towards Europe which is
constructive but prudent right hoggish
meeting in Berlin and Thomas feel like
here in London thanks for joining me